bonsoir nous sommes jeudi 28 janvier
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nos invités
et aussi des journalistes de la
rédaction
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition voisins le bretonneux entre dans
une nouvelle ère celle de la fibre
optique est la commune s'équipe pour
fournir à ses habitants internet en très
haut débit
retour sur l'opération qui doit débuter
avant cet été le gouvernement a lancé
différents dispositifs économiques pour
redresser l'emploi plan d'urgence ou à l
conneries qu'en pense le medef bertrand
de créer président du medef des yvelines
sera en plateau pour nous en parler en
ce1 les déserts médicaux une
problématique qui touche aussi les
yvelines lee ps en partenariat avec les
communes organise une journée dédiée aux
professionnels de la santé à montigny le
bretonneux sur ce sujet objectif attirer
les médecins sur le territoire et
opérations de déminage attrape une bombe
de 500 kg a été désamorcée aujourd'hui
rue casanova 400 personnes ont été
évacuées dès 13 heures pour des raisons
de sécurité 200 personnes ont été
mobilisés sur cette opération
les travaux de déminage ont nécessité la
fermeture de la rn 10 entre le pavillon
bleu à trappes et le croisement de la rn
58 à elancourt la route devraient rester
fermés jusqu'en fin d'après-midi
aujourd'hui et nous prenons à présent la
direction de voisins-le-bretonneux la
maire de la commune alexandra rose étiez
annoncé pendant ses voeux le déploiement
de la fibre optique dans l'intégralité
de la ville l'opération devrait débuter
avant l'été et se terminer à l'horizon
explications avec michael et demi
d'euros voisins le bretonneux va passer
en très haut débit la commune annonce
avoir signé un contrat avec l'opérateur
téléphonique orange pour déployer la
fibre optique dans toute la ville le
système permettra aux vicinaux de
transmettre et de recevoir des données
numériques plus rapidement je pense que
le ceux qui ont des débits très faibles
ils ont c'est un peu difficile pour eux
mêmes de surfer sur internet et ils ne
peuvent pas recevoir la télé par
internet
donc ils ont un nombre limité de chaîne
ils peuvent pas avoir la télé à la
demande donc voilà tout ça ça va ça va
apporter beaucoup plus de services ovi
ses doigts autre bonne nouvelle pour la
commune l'opération sera entièrement
financée par l'opérateur
la ville elle doit mettre tout ce qu'il
faut mettre en musique le projet mais
bien sûr ça ne coûte rien c'est le
l'opérateur qui finance tout ce
déploiement 0 euros et beaucoup de débit
pour les wc nord au total près de 4000
foyers vicinaux pourront profiter de ce
nouveau dispositif pour moi je ne pense
pas grand chose mais je me l'afrique
quand même installé par mes enfants et
petits enfants pour en profiter c'est
très bien c'est une bonne chose c'est
vrai qu'on a pas beaucoup de débit ici
ça rame de temps en temps donc nous ça
va encore au centre-ville ou mash mbow
par aka mes beaux parents kabyles un peu
plus loin et c'est un peu galère donc ça
va aller plus vite donc c'est très bien
que ça arrive et il faudrait que ça
arrive vite
les premiers travaux devraient débuter
avant l'été pour une livraison prévue à
l'horizon 2018
aussi bien pour les particuliers que
pour les entreprises les chiffres du
chômage ont été communiqués hier pour le
mois de décembre 2015 les chiffres sont
en hausse dans le département avec ce
centre 4470 demandeurs d'emploi inscrits
en catégorie à contre 64 milles 90 en
novembre le chômage connaît une
augmentation de 0,6 pour cent en
décembre 2015
dans les yvelines sur les catégories à b
et c le constat est le même car le taux
de chômage a augmenté de 1,1 pour cent
sur le territoire entre le mois de
novembre est le mois de décembre est de
5,9 pour cent sur un an à la même
période en ile de france le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi augmenté lui de 3%
en 2015 après qu'une hausse de 0,7 pour
cent au mois de descendre et à l'échelle
du pays enfin le pôle emploi a
enregistré 89 900 chômeurs
supplémentaires en 2015 et nous
continuons à parler emploi et économie
ce soir nous recevons bertrand de créer
de créer pardon président du medef des
événements saura vous
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
nous parlions à l'instant justement donc
de la hausse du chômage le medef s'est
dit alarmé par ces chiffres vous tire
également la sonnette d'alarmé dans les
yvelines
oui alors le medef tire cette dalle
armes
vous l'avez souligné dans vos chiffres
le département des yvelines fait plutôt
figure de bon élève si on peut dire par
rapport à la france au territoire et à
l'île de france mais il ya quand même
une hausse du chômage
le chômage est à fléaux et le bnf est
très mobilisée dans la lutte contre le
chômage alors justement françois
hollande par rapport au chômage et par
rapport à d'autres problématiques
économiques a annoncé un plomb un plan
d'urgence pour l'emploi
parmi ces annonces une prime d'embauché
immédiate de 2000 euros par an pour les
pme cela concernera donc dès aujourd'hui
et pour une durée de deux ans toute
entreprise de moins de 250 salariés qui
embauchera en cdi ou en cdd de plus de
six mois
ce que c'est un bon signe c'est une
mesure que vous attendiez c'est un très
bon signe et qu'on ne va pas bouder son
plaisir
merci au présent d'un public d'avoir
pris conscience que nos charges étaient
excessives toutefois eu un chef
d'entreprise ne vit pas de subventions
il n'attend pas des subventions
ce qu'on veut c'est vraiment régler le
problème définitivement être façon
pérenne c'est à dire baisser le coût du
travail baisser les charges qui pèsent
sur nous alors cette prime elle est très
bienvenue à titre personnel là c'est
même plus le président de l'afld qui
s'exprime c'est le chat l'entreprise que
je suis je vais embaucher
je vais j'ai pris des décisions
immédiates selon vous donc cette cette
annonce avoir bon ben ça aura des
conséquences
alors je peux pas les mesures
aujourd'hui vous avez combien mais moi
je peux vous dire simplement qu'à titre
personnel je suis en train de voir les
postes que j'ai pouvoir créer 45
salariés mais peut-être un ou deux
salariés c'est possible et je pense que
d'autres entreprises résonneront comme
moi parce qu'aujourd'hui chef de reprise
ils ont ils ont peur face à as droit du
travail trop complexe et trop collectif
y est face à as droit trop rigide à des
charges trop pesante face à un avenir
qui est totalement incertain et c'est le
vrai frein à l'embauché ce qui génère ce
chômage excessif alors que devant tous
les moyens
pour aujourd'hui retrouvé six le plein
emploi du bois résorber en grande partie
sauvage par une des seconds mesure c'est
l'assouplissement du temps de travail le
projet de loi porté par la ministre
merial elle connaît donc la réforme
future du code du travail peut être la
fin des 25 des 35 heures mais le rapport
badinter lui aussi on voit sur le site
internet donc du medef n'a pas été jugé
assez ambitieux il faut aller encore
plus loin
oui c'est que en fait brown a tout ça va
dans le bon sens mais d'abord ce sont
des annonces à nous on attend d'avoir du
concret parce que les annonces on en a
eu plusieurs fois je sais que des
ministres ont dit qu'ils nous est né un
1er nice même nous l'a dit mais dans les
actes
on voit pas toujours venir les réalités
donc nous sommes à peu mais sur un peu
chat échaudé sur les grandes annonces et
les mesures le rapport ban à terme oui
il est très général ian concret dans les
35 heures mais effectivement tout le
monde sait tout le monde sait que c'est
c'est une très mauvaise mesure
d'ailleurs si c'était une bonne mesure
je pense que tous les pays européens
auraient suivi tout le monde voudrait
nous sommes les seuls à l'avoir appliqué
alors les 35 heures doivent
effectivement le temps de travail doit
être revue en plus nous cette issue si
vous êtes de travail industriel
aujourd'hui le front de la france le
monde du travail avait une révolution ça
n'a plus de sens le temps de travail ça
a du sens sur un nouveau gain de la
chaîne dans une usine mais ce quelqu'un
qui a un employé libre service
aucun sens on peut glaner son avis là
tel on travaille c'est deuxième
productivité ça ne s'applique pas
partout donc globalement vous êtes assez
satisfait car lundi nous recevions
daniel verlet donc été président de la
chambre des métiers de l'artisanat les
yvelines qui lui sont bondés et que ces
annonces s'adresser plutôt aux grosses
entreprises et donc pas peut-être tpe et
aux pme
voilà qui sont souvent représentés par
des artisans notamment
écoutez moi je suis une pme je suis
patron d'une pme
l'ensemble même 80
oui même 100 % des adhérents du medef
yvelines sont des pme
je crois que le chiffre pour le medef
national ça doit être 80 classes pour
cent entreprises du medef ont moins de
10 salariés
voyez donc on n'est pas des des
grands entreprises non là je parle pas
ton temps tu patrons de pme
ces mesures ne satisfont nous allons
pouvoir embaucher ces sont des mesures
qui sont qui sont qui sont bonnes mais
pas suffisante aujourd'hui pas
suffisante il faut aller plus loin avec
des mesures très concrètes
oui vous savez les mesures ce qu'on veut
c'est sécurisation du droit de travail
voyez j'avais lu en cherchant des notes
qui ont été faites les sur les les
espagnols au permis dans leur accord
quand l'entreprise descendance appert
rassemble du chiffre d'affaires il peut
licencier parce que c'est ça une
entreprise qui licencie jamais un patron
de licence et par plaisir
il incite pour adapter ses coûts à sa
décharge et et à son entreprise
eh bien ces mesures prises devraient
espagnols ont dynamisé l'emploi et ont
permis de résoudre le chômage et ça n'a
rien coûté à l'état donc nous sommes ce
que nous demandons c'est un cdi
aujourd'hui plus sécurisé c'est des
accords traités en entreprise parce que
aujourd'hui les accords de branche n'ont
pas forcément une réalité objectif dans
nos pme justement que je représente et
l'accord dans l'entreprise devait primer
sur lowe's comme disons medef disons
également que les clauses de rupture
dont paris doit être prévu à l'avant
sont par la loi ou dans le contrat de
travail est effectivement la durée de
travail doit être revue harmonise donc
l'année à 2016 globalement commence bien
avec ces annonces selon vous l'année
dernière nous avions un vieux justement
les patrons à dans la rue il y avait eu
des manifestations assez rare pour être
souligné est-ce que des mouvements comme
ça de grande ampleur de colère si vous
justement vous n'avez pas à obtenir ce
que vous attendez pour être
envisageable c'est les patrons ne sont
pas des hommes qui en général vont dans
la rue sont des gens qui regardent
l'avenir qui oui pour nous les 35 heures
c'est jamais été quelque chose on a
toujours travaillé beaucoup plus donc
sont des notions que nous n'avons pas
par contre la colère oui face l'échec la
compréhension de ce que nous voulons
faire pourrait peut-être généré la
colère
enfin en général nous sommes plus aux
deux hommes mesurer et et savez là
l'écran de manifestations sont pas
forcément la bonne réponse
nous essayons de travailler par la
négociation par la compréhension par
l'explication c'est plutôt notre moto 2
de travail salaires nous parlions de à
la fibre optique l'adoption du numérique
justement nouvelles technologies c'est
un des objectifs
justement pour vous et le signalement
dans les yvelines abbas est anobli
montre change il faut le monde change et
il va encore changer plus vite
d'ailleurs le président gattaz était à
san francisco était à los angeles
enfin il a emmené avec l'idée d'aider
tout intime de jump start up française
pour montrer bien parce que nous avons
dû savoir faire nous avons de
l'excellence et et bien sûr nous sommes
très mobilisés sur tout ce qui est des
nouvelles technologies j'ai également
dans les yvelines ce quelque chose à
laquelle vous allez mettre l'accent à
nous y mettons l'accent très fortement
oui tout à fait il y aura des événements
organisés alors gpra le planning là
aujourd'hui pas pensé à vous l'amenez
mais effectivement
nous avons vainement qui seront
organisées merci beaucoup à bertrand à 2
crée d'être d'avoir répondu à nos
questions devenues en plateau et le mois
de janvier vous savez c'est le mois des
voeux mais également le mois de la
traditionnelle galette des rois
mardi 26 janvier la préfecture de
versailles a organisé sa dégustation
annuelle en compagnie d'une centaine
d'invités
un rendez vous depuis plusieurs
décennies qui met à l'honneur le travail
des artisans boulangers tout en se
régalant cette année c'est frédéric
charpentier boulanger à versailles qui a
été choisi pour la réaliser trois jours
de préparation ont été nécessaires pour
concocter cette galette d'un mètre de
diamètre pour un poids d'environ 16 kg
elle a été offerte par la fédération des
artisans boulangers pâtissiers des
yvelines la préfecture a tenu à leur
rendre hommage
pour nous c'est l'occasion à travers
cette petite manifestation de rendre
hommage ou 400 boulangers pâtissiers des
yvelines où 1700 salariés des
boulangeries pâtisseries qui joue un
rôle important dans l'animation de nos
territoires dans le lien social et pour
nous c'est l'occasion de lui remercié
tout simplement opération dimanche
dernier à voisins le bretonneux
l'association voisins adultes relais a
organisé son deuxième salon bien-être
ce salon proposait aux participants de
découvrir des médecines douces et
alternative par le biais de conférences
et d'ateliers comme par exemple comment
se soigner ou se sentir mieux grâce aux
fleurs de bach un reportage signé
william l robot thérapie sono thérapie
shiatsu ou encore relaxation par lâcher
prise
voilà un aperçu des différentes
pratiques que l'on pouvait découvrir
samedi dernier à voisins le bretonneux
au salon du bien-être conférences et
démonstrations étaient proposées toute
la journée pour s'initier à ces méthodes
peu conventionnelles mode furcajg mode
justement la vie étant stressante
actuellement pour que les grands comme
pour les petits de dison de vulgariser
entre guillemets ces méthodes ça aide
les personnes qui peuvent en avoir
besoin d'aller trouver à proximité des
intervenants illinois comme fabienne qui
présentait son livre au public un
travail basé sur l'harmonie des émotions
grâce au coaching en images aux cristaux
et aux fleurs de bach ont dit les fleurs
ne va puisque le docteur va qu'on avait
découvert 38
des fleurs qui ont des vertus ray
harmonisant ce qu'ils vont le calme et
qui vont nous permettre de produire
aucune part avoir une situation
problématique
ils vont nous permettre de reprendre le
moral un élixir qui contient l'essence
de la fleur que fabienne prescrit à ses
patients après consultation la personne
va me va me parler de ses émotions et
les mots de ses ressentis de ce qu'elle
ressort de ce qu'elle vit de ses peines
de ses colères de tout ce qu'elle peut
ressentir et au travers de 7 700 ce
panel je dirais de l'émotion eh bien on
va décider ensemble ça j'insiste là
dessus du cocktail de fleurs que l'on va
mettre dans son flacon une méthode
naturelle qui séduit de plus en plus
mais qui ne se substitue pas des soins
classiques
chaque année dans le monde ce sont
plusieurs dizaines de millions de fioles
de fleurs de bach qui s'écoule et c'est
une pratique de plus en plus répandue
qui se décline désormais de bien des
manières notamment dans le milieu
médical d'hypnose permet de modifier
l'état de conscience d'un individu elle
est utilisé aujourd'hui pour soigner des
douleurs physiques ou des as 10 sites
des addictions comme le tabac à
elancourt marlene intérêts et
sophrologue et pratiquer l'hypnose en
cabinet william elle a assisté à l'une
de ces séances regarder nouveau plonger
encore plus profondément dans cette
étape
tout commence par l'induction à la
détente tomber tous les maux de cordes
tout votre corps devient de plus en plus
une longue mise en condition de
relâchement pour atteindre l'état dicte
loose et l'hypnose c'est ni plus ni
moins qu'un état de ce qu on appelle un
état de conscience modifiée donc un état
qui n'est ni la veille ni le sommeil et
c'est un état en fait où notre
inconscient va être beaucoup plus
sensible et suggestive lé donc où les
suggestions qu'on va pouvoir faire vont
avoir plus du coup d'emprise l'objectif
de cette pratique
intégrer des suggestions dans l'esprit
du patient habits qu'elle souffre
l'insomnie et participe régulièrement à
ces séances pendant 30 minutes marilyn
ovale sur un rythme régulier concentrer
sur le poids des mots on va faire
attention par exemple à ne pas utiliser
de négation on va toujours proposé des
formulations positive clair pour que le
l'inconscient puisse vraiment entendre
et percevoir et du coup intégré ces
suggestions
la suggestion une fois intégré
marieville rappelle sa patiente
vous pouvez maintenant ouvrir les yeux
ou sans en l'air et qu'un la voie que
j'entends finalement c'est une voie qui
est dans ma tête qui me disent que je
dois faire comment me relaxer quand je
suis comme ça je me dis pas bon bah je
suis dans une salle il ya mon thérapeute
cayla et non c'est vraiment dans la tati
nement d'impression c'est ça réduire le
stress ou encore arrêter de fumer
la pratique de l'hypnose est de plus en
plus utilisée de nos jours également
entrer dans certains hôpitaux pour
remplacer des anesthésies générales
cette méthode reste non reconnue par
l'académie de médecine inciter les
jeunes médecins à s'installer dans les
yvelines c'est le but des journées
découverte de la médecine lui rps
l'union régionale des professionnels de
santé a organisé une journée sur ce
thème exercer dans les yvelines à l'ufr
santé simone veil de l'université saint
quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui le département a connu une
baisse de 16% du nombre de médecins
généralistes entre 2009 et 2015 il faut
donc y remédier les précisions de
mélanie poker comment travailler en
libéral ou s'installer dans un
territoire quand on débute dans le
métier
ce sont les réponses que sont venus
chercher médecins sages femmes
infirmiers ou encore interne
il ya un réel besoin
dans les yvelines comme en france autre
façon générale qui est des médecins qui
s'installent
il y avait il ya 30 ans 80 % des
étudiants diplômés s'installer en
médecine libérale et aujourd'hui ils
sont 13% à s'installer en libéral sur
saint quentin en yvelines les personnels
de santé dit de recours tels que les
médecins généralistes les
kinésithérapeutes ou encore les
dentistes sont quatre pour 5000
habitants un chiffre dans la moyenne
nationale à l'échelle de l'agglomération
l'institut de promotion de la santé peut
accompagner les professionnels
intéressés ce qu'on a pu faire pour
l'instant c'est c'est repérer ces
indicateurs
c'est un appui administratif au montage
des dossiers notamment par exemple les
diagnostics territoriaux des études de
faisabilité donc aider à mettre en place
et puis faciliter les liens avec
d'autres professionnels les centres
hospitaliers etc
sur un territoire sur l'agglomération il
n'y a pas deux comme une
saint-quentinoise considéré en déficit
mais celle de trappes est tout de même
classée par la rs l' agence régionale de
santé
comment fragilité sur l'offre dite de
premier recours et nous recevons à
présent sur ce plateau notre journaliste
sportif michael et demi d'euros pour la
chronique sport us ducey jeudi c'est bon
soir mickaël vous êtes accompagné siècle
suis accompagné aujourd'hui coup de
projecteur sur une marche mythique paris
mantes cette année la compétition fait
sa 81ème édition les marcheurs
s'élanceront de versailles ce samedi
dernier pour rejoindre mantes-la-jolie
54 km sont au programme de la randonnée
nocturne pour nous parler de 7 m
evènement nous recevrons sur ce plateau
l'organisateur patrick szewe ans c'est
ainsi que le président adjoint de l'as
mantaise francis du monde bonsoir
messieurs bonsoir soit patrick chiron
c'est ce que vous nous présenter le
parcours on va vous présenter par four
dans cette marche mythique qu'est né en
suite à un pari entre 13 personnes voilà
et ça s'est perpétuée tous les ans tous
les ans et jusqu'à aujourd'hui si la 81e
édition donc au départ 1 54 km de
versailles 1 39 kilomètres de ben où ils
partent à 1h du matin à 22 km 2
maul qui partent à 6 heures du matin et
un 10 km et de la cola marche familiale
de qui parle de jeux mobiles à 8 heures
du matin donc ils annoncent des
conditions climatiques assez
particulière ce week-end avec notamment
de la pluie saisonnière est ce qu'il y
aura
voilà est-ce qu'il n'ya pas un petit
danger dans cette course du goût non
parce que les les marcheurs se sont
préparés les majorettes les marcheurs se
sont équipés bon ce sont des en général
des habitués et pour éviter justement
d'avoir trop d'abondance et de respecter
certaines choses et de se préparer et
vous attendez combien de personnes pour
pour cette médiation en 1200 inscrits
donc en espérant que la météo soit
clémente et on en à 1 3202 remis 200
personnes au départ et c'est un chiffre
qui est stable depuis quelques années
oui c'est stable stable c'est-à-dire
toujours 3083 entre 3000 et 3500 tous
les ans et c'est une marche qui est
ouverte vraiment à tout le monde
tout le monde peut participer à paris
m'ont dit oui enfin de tout le monde pas
les enfants et les chiens ses 16 ans pas
moins de 16 ans pour l'épauler pour les
jeunes est ce qu'une fois qu'on a fait
une première fois donc là pour ce
parisien
on la refait vous avez voilà des
habitués qu'ils le veulent à fond
d'année en année oui nous avons des
marcheurs où ils sont à leur 40e marche
de 54 km des gens iront même jusqu'à
plus de 77 ans qui marche aussi
et quand vous êtes client pas cet
engouement qui leur reviennent à chaque
fois l'ambiance l'ambiance marche de
nuit et et quel est le profil du
marcheur typique il n'y a pas de profil
de marcheurs typique déjà avec un bon
entraînement sportif quand même faut pas
partir en faisant des paris comme on a
vu quelques fois des gens partir en
hauts talons
réponse c'est fini maintenant depuis
quelques années les gens sont préparés
au niveau condition physique au niveau
nutrition y'a pas de problème et comment
les gens terminal à la course ils sont
généralement à l'arrivée sont avait deux
cas soir d'août souffle 12 catégories
les gens qui arrivent à six heures parce
qu'il ya des gens qui arrivent à 6
heures entre 6 heures et 8 heures une
inover les gens sont très bien on sent
que ce sont des gens qui sont préparés
pour cette marche pédestre et derrière
on sent plus on arrive vers le la date
leur but est 11h30 on sent les gens très
très fatiguée c'est là que le samu ou
parce qu'ils rentrent en ligne de compte
nous avons quand même 45 personnes au
niveau de la croix rouge nous avons 12
points de logs de 4 podologue pardon 2e
c'est aux pattes
donc pour remettre tous les gens en
forme pour qu'il reparte du bon pied ce
cas de le dire
les spectateurs sont invités à
participer c'est normal à venir les
encourager
disons que toutes les familles des
marcheurs sont là au bord de la route
avec des ravitaillements privé parce que
nous avons nous sur le ce sur le
parcours trois ravitaillements ou les
tous les marcheurs peuvent se
ravitailler et de la soupe du café des
gâteaux des fruits secs ou tout est mis
en oeuvre pour que la marche se déroule
très bien de toute la nuit et les les
marcheurs sont applaudis et surtout l
arrivée et tout le monde les attend avec
une haie d'honneur et il y aurait une
nouvelle d'ici l'année prochaine
ces signes déjà signé oui je pense qu'
il n'y a pas de problème maintenant on
marche avec la sous-préfecture
versailles
nous sommes très très bien accueillis à
versailles au départ de ben aux sig a
aucun problème
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
bon courage pour l'organisation je pense
que vous n'allez pas beaucoup dormir ces
trois prochains jours
non mais bon
en tant que retraité nous avons entendre
nous de récupérer dans la semaine merci
à vous après 7e randonnée mythique nous
avons parlé rugby les plaisirs hu a
emmenés par leur capitaine françois le
vilain joueront ce week-end en fédérale
3 et un match très important florennes
les hommes coachés par jean miss ont
perdu le week-end dernier leur première
place de la poule
une au profit de ris orangis et daisy
roy devront donc se ressaisir contre
caen ce dimanche à 15 heures au stade
robert barran désir partira évidemment
grand favori de la rencontre et y
possède 21 points d'avancé sur leur
adversaire
je pense foraine que vous pouvez miser
une petite pièce sur les yvelinois vous
qui êtes une amatrice de pari en ligne
bien sûr mais quelle je l'écouté au vos
conseils on parle à présent rebonds et
paniers à trois points vous l'aurez
compris on termine à cette chronique par
des basques atteint en nationale 3
masculine trappe joue ce samedi ouvre à
20 heures au gymnase paul mallet les
trappistes recevront l'équipe de
barjouville pour bonifier leur victoire
de la semaine dernière contre viry
châtillon les hommes de mustapha el
hafidi doivent absolument l'emporter
pour garder une infime chance d'accéder
à la nationale 2 l'année prochaine pour
accomplir son objectif trappe doit
réaliser un quasi sans faute pour
réaliser cet exploit les saint
quentinois compte sur le soutien de leur
public
voilà vous connaissez tous les rendez
vous sportifs du week-end dans lé
département florane j'espère que j'étais
assez complet et bien merci michael 7 à
nos téléspectateurs d'en juger bien
évidemment ils peuvent d'ailleurs vous
le diront vous contactons sur le twitter
on vous retrouve lundi pour le 7-8 sport
une mission qui devrait prendre un
accent américain je crois tout à fait
floral
nous recevrons l'équipe de football
américain des templiers d'elancourt
l'équipe jouera à reprendre la
compétition le samedi à 6 février nous
parlerons également baseball avec les
cougars de montigny-le-bretonneux une
équipe qui évolue en deuxième division
pour un art si beaucoup michael à lundi
peut-être présenterez-vous cette
émission en anglais nous le verrons ce
sera le suspense on verra c'est la fin
de cette édition merci nous avoir suivis
demain vous avez rendez vous avec
wilfrid de réchy pour l'essentiel de
l'actualité de la semaine vous
retrouverez toutes vos idées de sorties
avec mélanie potier pour le 7-8 week-end
et quant à moi je vous retrouve lundi
pour une nouvelle édition du journal je
vous souhaite donc une très bonne soirée
et un excellent week end